you are a real actor you are I would
call you a method actor you were in some
movie I don't remember what the movie
was but the story I heard was you were
like being kidnapped or something and in
your wallet was the ransom money and you
said how you do man did to know how much
money the ransom money was because you
had a stuff your wallet Foley exact mine
because you said the way you would sit
it would depend on how much money you
had on your wallet
well no wasn't that that's it that's a
little like heavy duty method no it was
basically was the bag we had to carry
like three million dollars when I said
how big is in cash and you know like you
know I've had a hundred two hundred
dollars in my back pocket and I have a
problem so how much is it gonna be we
found a detail and it was three gym bags
we had to fill and it was heavy and you
said man now the thieves are walking
they're not running out right that's
true difference yeah see I like that
detail in the movie that's why you got
the Academy Award when I did my movie I
want to make sure the microphones were
used correctly so that when radio people
saw it they saw that the thing look real
I liked your movie thank you did you
burn yourself with cigarettes too when
you were prepared why would you burn
yourself a cigarettes to prepare for a
movie you know that was feeling Loathing
in Las Vegas right based on Hunter
Hearst Thompson's a book and it's based
on a true story that happened with
Hunter and this other guy that in the
movie is dr. gonzo and his real name was
Oscar Acosta
I saw a picture of Oscar Acosta and I
saw these marks around his wrist and and
I asked hunter
oh that's he put out cigarettes on his
wrist I go what for [ __ ] with people wow
you know I'm playing Oscar's a little
bit realize already and I just did it
you know but it's the thing that you do
when you're young as an actor and you'd
like really into it anyway circus in
order to relate to the character you
needed to burn your wrists with
cigarettes you don't do that so you had
to gain 40 something pounds for a
migraine
do that now right because I said you
know what Howard it it messed me up
horse I I didn't do it professionally I
went out and I bought doughnuts and I
said I can - wait I can do it and I
didn't sit down and do what I what you
need to do to be like really you know
careful with that stuff and so you
destroyed yourself for your art well
yeah well you are a terrific actor you
know that don't you I'm very proud of
what you're doing thank you
you